Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Would you harm a stranger just because someone in a lab coat told you to? In 1961,
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。如果有人穿着实验服让你伤害一个陌生人，你会照做吗？1961年，
Stanley Milgram wanted to find out and the results shocked the world. But why was this so important and what does it tell us about human nature today? Hi, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist, and today we are diving into one of the most famous and controversial psychology experiments of all time, the Milgram experiment. This study wasn't just about obedience, it really did force us to confront uncomfortable truths about human nature. Why do ordinary people follow orders even when those orders are harmful? And of course, what does this mean for how we navigate authority in our modern lives today?
Stanley Milgram想找出答案，结果震惊了世界。但这为什么如此重要？它对今天的人性有何启示？你好，我是临床心理学家Marianne Trent博士。今天，我们将深入探讨心理学史上最著名、最具争议的实验之一——米尔格拉姆实验（Milgram experiment）。这项研究不仅仅关于服从，它确实迫使我们面对关于人性的令人不安的真相。为什么普通人在命令有害时依然会服从？当然，这对我们今天如何在现代生活中应对权威意味着什么？
In this episode, I'll take you through what happened during the experiment, why it sparked so much debate and what lessons still apply today. Let's dive in. Picture this, you're in a lab at Yale University in the early 1960s. You've signed up for a study on learning and memory, or so you think. And when you arrive, you're paired with another participant, again, so you think, and you have a bit of a lucky dip choosing pieces of paper to decide who will be the learner and who will be the teacher in reality though of course the draw is completely rigged the person you are paired with is in on the whole thing they're an actor working with the experimenter to see what
在本期节目中，我将带你了解实验过程中发生了什么，为什么它引发了如此多的争论，以及今天依然适用的教训。让我们开始吧。想象一下，你身处20世纪60年代初耶鲁大学的一间实验室里。你报名参加了一项关于学习和记忆的研究，或者说你以为是这样。当你到达时，你被分配给另一位参与者（你以为是这样），你们通过抽签决定谁是学习者，谁是教师。但实际上，抽签完全是预先安排好的。与你搭档的人是知情者，他们是一名演员，与实验者合作来观察
you will do you are both in separate rooms so you can't directly see one another for the duration of the experiment and that is one of the key pieces of information. It's also a key deception. So your role as the teacher is to ask the learner questions. If they get an answer wrong you're instructed to administer an electric shock and the crux of the whole experiment is that the shocks start small, but increase with each mistake. The machine in front of you that you're asked to use to dish out these punishments has labels
你会怎么做。你们都在不同的房间里，所以在实验期间你们无法直接看到对方，这是关键信息之一。这也是一个关键的欺骗手段。作为教师，你的任务是向学习者提问。如果他们答错了，你被指示给予电击。整个实验的核心在于，电击从轻微开始，但随着错误次数的增加而增强。你面前用来实施惩罚的机器上贴着标签，
which range from slight shock to danger, severe shock, and finally, XXX. Ah! What we know as we look back is that no shocks were administered, but the people who were acting as the teachers, in this case you, would not know that. You'd think this was the real deal. At first, the learners' mistakes are met with kind of mild discomfort, really, but as the shocks increase, so does their reaction and understandably so. You start to hear groans and then screams and then pounding on the wall next to you. Eventually, there's silence and you're told by the experiment organisers that the
范围从轻微电击到危险、严重电击，最后是XXX。啊！回过头来看，我们知道并没有真正实施电击，但作为教师的参与者（也就是你）并不知道这一点。你会以为这是真的。起初，学习者的错误只会引起轻微的不适，但随着电击增强，他们的反应也随之加剧，这是可以理解的。你开始听到呻吟声，然后是尖叫声，接着是隔壁墙上的撞击声。最终，一切归于沉寂，实验组织者告诉你，
silence means they're not responding and you should treat it as a wrong answer. If you hesitate, the experimenter who is dressed in a lab coat urges you to continue, saying phrases like, the experiment requires that you continue, or you have no other choice, you must go on. Wow, what would you do? So here is what Milgram found. 65% of participants delivered the highest available voltage shock of what they believed was 450 volts, even though sometimes they were visibly distressed whilst pressing those buttons. Many people expressed discomfort, some even protested about doing it, but the majority obeyed that authority figure in the white coat. This experiment revealed something profound,
沉默意味着他们没有反应，你应该将其视为错误答案。如果你犹豫不决，穿着实验服的实验者会催促你继续，说出诸如“实验要求你继续”、“你别无选择，你必须继续”之类的话。哇，你会怎么做？这就是Milgram的发现：65%的参与者施加了他们认为高达450伏的最高电压电击，尽管有时他们在按下按钮时明显感到痛苦。许多人表达了不适，有些人甚至抗议这样做，但大多数人还是服从了那个穿白大褂的权威人物。这个实验揭示了一些深刻的东西，
the power of perceived authority. Ordinary people under the right conditions can and do perform actions that go against their moral beliefs simply because they're told to. The Milgram experiment has become a cornerstone for psychology, but it's not without its controversy. Why it matters is that this study showed how deeply ingrained obedience to authority is. It wasn't about bad people doing bad things. It was about just normal individuals like you and me prioritizing instructions over their moral conscience and compass. So what psychological mechanisms have been going on here? We've got something called diffusion of responsibility.
即感知权威的力量。在适当的条件下，普通人能够并且确实会做出违背其道德信念的行为，仅仅因为他们被告知要这样做。米尔格拉姆实验已成为心理学的基石，但它并非没有争议。它之所以重要，是因为这项研究展示了对权威的服从是多么根深蒂固。这并不是坏人在做坏事，而是像你我一样的普通人将指令置于道德良知和准则之上。那么，这里发生了什么心理机制呢？我们称之为“责任分散”。
That's where participants feel that the experimenter was ultimately responsible for their outcomes and not themselves. This means that they don't really feel like it was their choice. They were simply doing what they were told to do. It's what we understand with the term of cognitive dissonance, how we make ourselves feel okay with an idea that we're not actually that comfortable with. It's the adjustments we make to make that lay flat for us. We've also got the power of authority to consider. The lab coat, the setting, the professional tone, the university building, and all of these elements combined really did reinforce the legitimacy of
这就是参与者认为实验者最终对结果负责，而不是他们自己。这意味着他们并不觉得这是自己的选择。他们只是在做被告知要做的事情。这就是我们所理解的“认知失调”——我们如何让自己接受一个实际上并不舒服的想法。这是我们为了让它在心理上变得合理而做的调整。我们还要考虑权威的力量。白大褂、环境、专业的语气、大学建筑，所有这些元素结合在一起，确实强化了
that authority figure. Ethical controversy is a massive one because Milgram's study also raised significant ethical questions. Participants were deceived into thinking they were causing real and actual harm, leading to extreme stress and emotional conflict. This study, alongside others, helped shape modern ethical guidelines for psychological research, including the necessity of what we know as informed consent and debriefing. It's why if you are doing any research in psychology these days, that you have to complete a ton of paperwork and attend ethics panels and think about all of the possible pros and
那个权威人物的合法性。伦理争议是一个巨大的问题，因为Milgram的研究也引发了重大的伦理质疑。参与者被欺骗，以为自己在造成真实且实际的伤害，导致了极度的压力和情感冲突。这项研究与其他研究一起，帮助塑造了现代心理学研究的伦理准则，包括我们所知的“知情同意”和“事后说明”的必要性。这就是为什么如果你现在进行任何心理学研究，你必须完成大量的文书工作，参加伦理委员会，并考虑参与者可能面临的所有利弊，
cons of people taking part. It also is why pretty often ethics panels say no to research proposals. Let's have a think about the specific time that the Milgram experiment took place. So of course it was the 1960s and it was deeply influenced by the historical context of the Second World War. In the aftermath of the Holocaust, society was really trying to grapple with understanding how soldiers, and in fact ordinary citizens, could commit such atrocities simply by being ordered to by the authoritarian regimes. The
这也是为什么伦理委员会经常拒绝研究提案的原因。让我们思考一下米尔格拉姆实验发生的特定时期。当然，那是20世纪60年代，深受第二次世界大战历史背景的影响。在大屠杀之后，社会确实在努力理解士兵，甚至普通公民，是如何仅仅因为独裁政权的命令就犯下如此暴行的。
Nuremberg trials highlighted how just following orders was often used as a defence, which raised complex moral questions about obedience and personal accountability. Even in more recent conflicts, soldiers in combat zones face moral dilemmas that echo the themes of Milgram's work. How far should one go to follow orders? And when does blind obedience cross ethical boundaries? These are questions that we continue to confront in modern times, from the military to everyday situations where authority figures wield power over others. So what does this mean for us today? Authority in the modern world is such that one tweet can have monumental consequences in today's connected world. For instance, a recent case saw a woman sentenced to 31 months in prison for a
纽伦堡审判强调了“仅仅是服从命令”经常被用作辩护，这引发了关于服从和个人责任的复杂道德问题。即使在最近的冲突中，战斗区的士兵也面临着与Milgram研究主题相呼应的道德困境。一个人应该在多大程度上服从命令？盲目服从何时跨越了道德界限？这些是我们今天在现代社会中继续面对的问题，从军队到权威人物对他人行使权力的日常情况。那么这对我们今天意味着什么？现代世界的权威使得一条推文在当今互联的世界中可能产生巨大的后果。例如，最近的一个案例中，一名女子因
single inflammatory post that incited racial hatred. This modern example shows how actions driven by perceived authority or impulsive reactions can spiral into serious repercussions, reminding us of the key Milgram experiments lessons about obedience and responsibility. Moral dilemmas. Imagine a whistleblower in a company. They might know something is wrong but feel pressured to stay silent because their boss insists that they do. The Milgram experiment helps us to understand the psychological cost of resisting authority and why it's so hard to do. Critical thinking. Milgram's work reminds us to question authority and to think critically about our own actions. Are we acting out of genuine belief or are we just following orders? So what
一条煽动种族仇恨的煽动性帖子被判入狱31个月。这个现代例子展示了由感知权威或冲动反应驱动的行为如何可能演变成严重的后果，提醒我们米尔格拉姆实验关于服从和责任的关键教训。道德困境：想象一下公司里的举报人。他们可能知道某事是错的，但因为老板坚持要求，他们感到被迫保持沉默。米尔格拉姆实验帮助我们理解抵制权威的心理成本，以及为什么这样做如此困难。批判性思维：Milgram的工作提醒我们要质疑权威，并批判性地思考我们自己的行为。我们是出于真正的信念行事，还是仅仅在服从命令？那么
can we learn from the Milgram experiment? It's a sobering reminder of how authority can shape behaviour, often in ways we don't expect. But it also gives us the tools to reflect, to question and to stand up for what we know is right. I want to leave you with a question. What would you have done in that situation? Do you think you would have obeyed or would you have resisted? Do let me know in the comments. If you found this video thought-provoking don't forget to like, to subscribe and to share it with others in your network who might also enjoy about learning about the fascinating and sometimes uncomfortable and grisly truths of real human behavior. If you did want to buy me a cup of herbal tea to say thank you, then please do check out the link in any of my social media bios.
我们能从米尔格拉姆实验中学到什么？这是一个清醒的提醒，提醒我们权威如何塑造行为，往往以我们意想不到的方式。但它也给了我们反思、质疑和坚持我们认为正确的事情的工具。我想留给你一个问题：在那样的情境下，你会怎么做？你认为你会服从还是会抵制？请在评论区告诉我。如果你觉得这个视频发人深省，别忘了点赞、订阅并分享给你的社交圈中可能也喜欢了解真实人类行为中那些迷人、有时令人不安且残酷真相的人。如果你想请我喝杯花草茶以示感谢，请查看我任何社交媒体简介中的链接。
Please do also come along to my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community. And if it's your time and you're ready for the next step, please do consider The Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and the Clinical Psychologist Collective are also really great books which will help you to build on your reflective practice and to see how others put that into practice too. If you need to reflect on grief or on autism then please do check out the grief collective and the autistic anthology. Thank you so much for watching. podcast that you'll say you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne
也请加入我的免费Facebook群组“Aspiring Psychologist Community”。如果时机成熟，你准备好迈出下一步，请考虑“Aspiring Psychologist”会员资格，每月仅需30英镑起，无最低期限要求。《The Aspiring Psychologist Collective》和《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》也是非常棒的书籍，将帮助你建立反思实践，并看看其他人是如何将其付诸实践的。如果你需要反思悲伤或自闭症，请查看《The Grief Collective》和《The Autistic Anthology》。非常感谢你的观看。播客，你会说你已经在成为合格心理学家的路上了，这就是《The Aspiring Psychologist with Dr. Marianne》。
my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist
我叫Yana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于通往那里的途径竟然如此之多，没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，
I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。此集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。